a set of philosophy exam scores are
normally distributed with a mean of 40
points and a standard deviation of 3
points
ludwig got a score of 47.5
points on the exam
what proportion of exam scores are
higher than ludwig's score give your
answer correct to four decimal places so
let's just visualize what's going on
here
so the scores are normally distributed
so it would look like
this
so the distribution would look something
like that trying to make that pretty
symmetric looking
the mean
is 40 points
so that would be 40 points right over
there standard deviation is three points
so this could be one standard deviation
above the mean that would be one
standard deviation below the mean and
once again this is just very rough and
so this would be 43 this would be 37
right over here and they say ludwig got
a score of 47.5
points on the exam
so ludwig's score is going to be
someplace around here
so ludwig got a 47.5
on the on the exam
and they're saying what proportion of
exam scores are higher than ludwig's
score so we need to do is figure out
what is the area under the normal
distribution curve that is above 47.5
so the way we will tackle this is we
will figure out the z-score for 47.5
how many standard deviations above the
mean is that
then we will look at a z table to figure
out what proportion is below that
because that's what z tables give us
they give us the proportion that is
below
a certain z-score
and then we could take one minus that to
figure out the proportion
that is above remember the entire area
under the curve is one so if we can
figure out this orange area and take one
minus that we're going to get the red
area so let's do that so first of all
let's figure out the z score for 47.5
so let's see we would take
47.5
and we would subtract the mean so this
is his score we'll subtract the mean
minus 40. we know what that's going to
be that's 7.5 so that's how much more
above the mean but how many standard
deviations is that
well each standard deviation is 3. so
what's 7.5 divided by 3. this just means
the previous answer divided by 3.
so here's 2.5 standard deviations above
the mean
so the z-score here
z-score
here is a positive 2.5 if he was below
the mean it would be a negative so now
we can look at a z-table to figure out
what proportion is less than 2.5
standard deviations above the mean so
that will give us that orange and then
we'll subtract that from one
so let's get our z table
so here we go and we've already done
this in previous videos but what's going
on here is this left column gives us our
z score up to the tenths place and then
these other columns give us the hundreds
place so what we want to do is find 2.5
right over here on the left and it's
actually going to be 2.50 there's no
there's zero hundredths here so we're
going to we want to look up 2.50 so let
me scroll my z table
so i'm going to go down to
2.5 all right i think i am there
so what i have here
so i have 2.5 so i am going to be in
this row
and it's now scrolled off but this first
column we saw this is two this is the
hundredths place and this is zero
hundredths and so
2.50 puts us right over here now you
might be tempted to say okay that's the
proportion that scores higher than
ludwig but you'd be wrong this is the
proportion that scores lower than ludwig
so what we want to do is take 1 minus
this value so let me get my calculator
out again
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
take
minus this
1 minus 0.9938
is equal to now this is so this is the
proportion that scores less than ludwig
1 minus that is going to be the
proportion that scores more than him the
reason why we had to do this is because
the z table gives us the proportion less
than a certain z-score
so this gives us right over here
0.0062 so that's the proportion if you
thought of in percent it would be
0.62 percent scores higher than ludwig
and that makes sense because ludwig
scored over two standard deviations all
two and a half standard deviations above
the mean
so our answer here is 0.0062
so this is going to be
0.0062 that's the proportion of exam
scores higher than ludwig's score